SPEAKER_00: Good afternoon, Mark. Ready to tackle retirement planning?
SPEAKER_01: I think so. Though I'm not sure I'm-- I'm ready to actually retire yet.
SPEAKER_00: That's fine - planning is about having options. You're forty-seven now, so we have time to adjust the strategy as things evolve.
SPEAKER_01: Right. I keep hearing I should aim for a million dollars, but that seems... daunting.
SPEAKER_00: The magic number depends on your expected expenses. Let's start there - what do you think you'll spend annually in retirement?
SPEAKER_01: I have no idea. What I spend now? Less? I honestly haven't thought about it.
SPEAKER_00: That's pretty common. What are you spending now, roughly?
SPEAKER_01: Maybe seventy thousand a year? My mortgage will be paid off by then, so maybe sixty?
SPEAKER_00: Good starting point. The rule of thumb is you need about seventy to eighty percent of pre-retirement income, but it varies a lot.
SPEAKER_01: Why seventy to eighty percent?
SPEAKER_00: Well, you're no longer saving for retirement, your mortgage is gone, maybe lower transportation costs. But healthcare might cost more, and you'll have more time to spend money on hobbies.
SPEAKER_01: So sixty thousand annually might be realistic?
SPEAKER_00: Could be. Now, let's look at your retirement income sources. In Canada, you'll have CPP, OAS, plus your own savings.
SPEAKER_01: How much are CPP and OAS worth?
SPEAKER_00: CPP maxes out around fifteen thousand annually if you contribute the maximum for thirty-nine years. OAS is about seven thousand. Both indexed too inflation.
SPEAKER_01: So maybe twenty-two thousand from government sources?
SPEAKER_00: That's if you qualify for the full amounts. CPP depends on your contribution history. What's your current income?
SPEAKER_01: About ninety-five thousand.
SPEAKER_00: Good, so you're contributing close to the CPP maximum. But you need to contribute for... let me think... most of your working career to get the full benefit.
SPEAKER_01: I've been working steadily since I was twenty-two.
SPEAKER_00: That helps. Though early years you probably weren't at the maximum. Let's assume you'll get about thirteen thousand from CPP.
SPEAKER_01: And OAS is automatic?
SPEAKER_00: If you're a Canadian resident for forty years after age eighteen. But it gets clawed back at higher income levels. Starts phasing out around... um... eighty thousand in retirement income, I think.
SPEAKER_01: Would that affect me?
SPEAKER_00: Depends how much you accumulate. If you need sixty thousand annually and get twenty thousand from CPP and OAS, you need forty thousand from your own savings.
SPEAKER_01: What's the four percent rule?
SPEAKER_00: The idea that you can withdraw four percent of your portfolio annually without running out of money. So for forty thousand annually, you'd need a million dollars.
SPEAKER_01: There's that million again.
SPEAKER_00: It's not a magic number though. The four percent rule was based on US data and assumes a thirty-year retirement. Your situation might be different.
SPEAKER_01: Different how?
SPEAKER_00: Well, Canadians have CPP and OAS as a base. Plus our healthcare system. And maybe you'll work part-time in retirement, or your expenses will be lower than expected.
SPEAKER_01: What's your current portfolio worth?
SPEAKER_00: Um, that was my question for you. What have you accumulated so far?
SPEAKER_01: Right, sorry. RRSP has about two hundred thousand. TFSA maybe sixty.
SPEAKER_00: Any employer pension?
SPEAKER_01: Just a group RRSP with matching.
SPEAKER_00: How much are you contributing annually?
SPEAKER_01: About twelve thousand to the RRSP, six thousand to TFSA.
SPEAKER_00: Good savings rate. What's the employer matching?
SPEAKER_01: They match half of what I put in, up to three percent of salary.
SPEAKER_00: So about three thousand annually in free money. That's huge - make sure you're getting the full match.
SPEAKER_01: I am. So total savings is twenty-one thousand?
SPEAKER_00: Right - twelve plus six plus three. That's over twenty percent of your gross income. Very strong savings rate.
SPEAKER_01: But will it be enough?
SPEAKER_00: Let's run the numbers. You have two sixty thousand now, saving twenty-one thousand annually, eighteen years until retirement at sixty-five.
SPEAKER_01: What return should we assume?
SPEAKER_00: Long-term, maybe six to seven percent nominal. Let's use six percent to be conservative. Your current balance grows to... let me calculate... about seven fifty thousand.
SPEAKER_01: And the annual contributions?
SPEAKER_00: Twenty-one thousand annually for eighteen years at six percent... that's another six hundred thousand or so. Total around one point three five million.
SPEAKER_01: That's more than the million I thought I needed.
SPEAKER_00: Right, and remember, that million was for forty thousand annually. At four percent, one point three five million supports fifty-four thousand in withdrawals.
SPEAKER_01: Plus the twenty thousand from CPP and OAS?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. So you'd have over seventy thousand in retirement income. More than the sixty you thought you'd need.
SPEAKER_01: That sounds... almost too good to be true.
SPEAKER_00: Well, there are risks. Investment returns might be lower, inflation could be higher, you might live longer than expected.
SPEAKER_01: What if returns are only five percent?
SPEAKER_00: Then you'd end up with maybe one point one million instead. Still enough for forty-four thousand annually, plus government benefits.
SPEAKER_01: What about inflation?
SPEAKER_00: That's why we use real returns - returns above inflation. But you're right to worry. If inflation averages three percent, sixty thousand today equals about a hundred thousand in eighteen years.
SPEAKER_01: So I might need more than I thought?
SPEAKER_00: Maybe. But your investments should grow with inflation too. And CPP and OAS are indexed, so they maintain purchasing power.
SPEAKER_01: What about healthcare costs?
SPEAKER_00: Canada's system covers most basics, but you might want private insurance for things like prescription drugs, dental, vision. Maybe two thousand annually?
SPEAKER_01: That's not too bad.
SPEAKER_00: No, we're lucky that way. In the US, retirees spend fifteen to twenty thousand annually on healthcare.
SPEAKER_01: What about long-term care?
SPEAKER_00: That's less predictable. Home care or assisted living can be expensive. Maybe budget five hundred thousand for potential long-term care needs.
SPEAKER_01: Half a million? That's a lot.
SPEAKER_00: You might not need it, but it's good to plan for the possibility. That's where your home equity could help.
SPEAKER_01: I hadn't thought about the house.
SPEAKER_00: Many retirees downsize and use the proceeds to fund retirement. What's your house worth?
SPEAKER_01: About six hundred thousand now.
SPEAKER_00: So that's significant wealth beyond your investment accounts. If you downsize to a four hundred thousand place, that's two hundred thousand extra for retirement.
SPEAKER_01: I'd hate to leave the neighborhood though.
SPEAKER_00: You don't have to decide now. The point is you have options. The house is like a backup plan.
SPEAKER_01: What about retiring earlier than sixty-five?
SPEAKER_00: That's trickier. You can't get CPP until sixty, OAS until sixty-five. So you'd need to bridge that gap with your own savings.
SPEAKER_01: How much extra would I need?
SPEAKER_00: If you retired at sixty, you'd need five years of expenses before any government benefits. Maybe three hundred thousand extra.
SPEAKER_01: That seems doable if I keep saving.
SPEAKER_00: It might be. Though early CPP comes at a penalty - about point six percent per month before age sixty-five.
SPEAKER_01: So thirty-six percent less if I take it at sixty?
SPEAKER_00: Right, permanently. Though if you're not working, you might prefer some income over no income.
SPEAKER_01: What about working part-time in retirement?
SPEAKER_00: That's becoming very common. Even fifteen thousand annually from part-time work makes a big difference to your financial security.
SPEAKER_01: And it might be more fulfilling than full retirement.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Many people find complete retirement boring. A consulting gig or part-time role can provide purpose and income.
SPEAKER_01: What about tax planning in retirement?
SPEAKER_00: That's crucial. You'll likely be in a lower tax bracket, so withdrawing from RRSPs becomes more attractive than when you were working.
SPEAKER_01: Should I convert RRSPs to RRIFs right away?
SPEAKER_00: You have to by age seventy-one. But you might want to do it earlier to start the income splitting with your spouse.
SPEAKER_01: Income splitting?
SPEAKER_00: After age sixty-five, you can split eligible pension income - including RRIF withdrawals - with your spouse. Helps minimize total taxes.
SPEAKER_01: My wife has her own retirement savings though.
SPEAKER_00: Even better. You can optimize withdrawals from both accounts to stay in lower tax brackets.
SPEAKER_01: This is getting complicated.
SPEAKER_00: It can be. That's why many retirees work with accountants or fee-for-service planners to optimize their withdrawal strategies.
SPEAKER_01: What about OAS clawback?
SPEAKER_00: If your net income exceeds about eighty-one thousand, you start losing OAS. At one hundred thirty thousand, it's completely gone.
SPEAKER_01: So I want to stay under eighty-one thousand?
SPEAKER_00: It's something to consider. Though don't let the tax tail wag the investment dog. Better to have higher income and pay some clawback.
SPEAKER_01: What about leaving money to kids?
SPEAKER_00: That changes the calculation entirely. If you want to leave an inheritance, you need to save more or spend less.
SPEAKER_01: I'd like to leave them something, but not at the expense of my own security.
SPEAKER_00: That's wise. The best gift to your kids is not being a financial burden. If there's money left over, that's a bonus.
SPEAKER_01: What's my biggest risk in retirement planning?
SPEAKER_00: Longevity risk - living longer than expected. A sixty-five-year-old male has a decent chance of living to ninety.
SPEAKER_01: Twenty-five years of retirement?
SPEAKER_00: Or more. That's why the four percent rule assumes thirty years. Your money needs to last a long time.
SPEAKER_01: What if I run out of money?
SPEAKER_00: Well, you'd still have CPP and OAS. Plus your house could be sold or mortgaged. And there are government supports for low-income seniors.
SPEAKER_01: Not exactly the retirement I'm picturing.
SPEAKER_00: Right, that's why we plan. The projections show you should be fine if you stick to your current savings rate.
SPEAKER_01: What if I want to retire earlier?
SPEAKER_00: Then you might need to save more now, or plan for part-time income, or accept a more modest lifestyle in early retirement.
SPEAKER_01: How much more would I need to save?
SPEAKER_00: For retirement at sixty? Maybe another five thousand annually. That's achievable if you get raises or bonuses.
SPEAKER_01: Or if I can increase my TFSA contributions.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. The contribution room increases each year, so you'll have more flexibility as time goes on.
SPEAKER_01: This has been really helpful. I feel much more confident about retirement.
SPEAKER_00: Good. The key is starting early and being consistent. You're on track for a comfortable retirement if you stick with the plan.
SPEAKER_01: And I have options if things change.
SPEAKER_00: Right. That's the beauty of planning ahead - you maintain flexibility to adjust as life happens.